greetings from podcast Ville its
Thursday the 18th of April the church is
brought to you by quip one of the most
important things we do for our health
every day is brushing our teeth yet most
of us don't do it properly quip is the
better electric toothbrush created by
dentist and designers you're sitting
there going Joey why quit why cuz it's
sonic vibrations gentle enough on your
sensitive gums and why because people
brush too hard and someone like the
tooth brushes a too abrasive with quip
it's got a two-minute timer built-in
that pulses every 30 seconds to remind
you when to switch sides helping guide a
full and even cleaner brush what I'm
gonna do is this why you love quit why I
love quit is because I bring it on the
road with me one charge lasts forever it
doesn't take up too much space it's got
a thing like stick on and it sticks
right up so it air dries that's why I
love quick it's sanitary and like I said
dentists love it now what I'm gonna do
is this they're backed by over 20,000
dental professionals that's the real
reason I love quit quit starts at just
25 hours and if you go too quick get
quit get quick comm slash Joey right now
you're gonna get your first refill pack
for free with equip electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack for free
I'd get quit coms last Joey that's gtq
uip dot-com slash Joey the church is
also brought to you by let me tell you
something sometimes I'm sick and tired
of [ __ ] shaving my nutsack [ __ ]
area around my dick do you know why cuz
I feel like my wife's gonna slip and cut
it the [ __ ] off it's the most anxiety
I've ever had in my goddamn life but
guess what the suffering ends now with
manscape you get it done without the
pain without the anxiety without closing
your eyes you like Joey why because they
got put precision tools for the family
[ __ ] you Jules you understand me your
little diamonds are gonna be [ __ ]
shining and cleaner manscape has
redesigned the electric razor what I
want to do is what I want you to do is
this at man
scapegoat calm you you can get anything
you need to make your balls tip-top
Magoo they'll be shining they'll smell
good and they'll keep your dick looking
[ __ ] beautiful like Sophia Loren you
understand me if this is the first time
you've considered manscaping they got a
deal for you plus you're [ __ ] half
[ __ ] you got to be ready for the
summertime
you don't want your dick to smell like a
Greek [ __ ] salad if this is the time
you've considered manscaping we got a
deal for you you ready we got the
perfect package which comes with a
lawnmower and the safety plus or a
safety razor plus it comes with a cop
crop preserver a specially formulated
deodorant so your balls don't stink like
10 dead [ __ ] sandals and the Reviver
a spritz that tones and refreshes your
[ __ ] whole self being so the stick
looks good the balls look good
everything looks good now the church
family can get 20% off your first order
when you use the code Church CH you are
CH at manscape comm and if you are the
perfect package to also throw on a
beautiful free travel bag nice and big
when you use code Church that's manscape
comm use promo code church for 20% off
your first order keep your balls clean
this is summertime the podcast is also
brought to you by one of my all-time
favorites like manscaped on it why
because their supplements are tip-top
Magoo number one in the industry from
the Alpha brain for the shroom tech you
cannot go wrong with on it o frank
caliendo's miss [ __ ] it's the
18th of april take this [ __ ]
muley how the hell have you been miss
huh old Oh aye and you're older than me
I think 56 56 and you just made me feel
90 thank you for that you look beautiful
I'm a handsome man are you feeling I'm
trying listen I'm doing all right
it's funny cuz I watch a bunch of the
show I knew about your show we've known
each other for a while but more in
passing a little bit once in a while
just coming across each other but I
wanted to get make it the tone right for
the show I don't want to come on and be
jokey and you're not joke you're
conversational we just
real honest happens that's true and I
where I'm trying to go in in life and
you know entertainment as well because
that but it is funny because even
looking at you and watching you there's
a duality and there's something that I
see in people that's maybe other people
see it - I don't want to sound like I've
got superpowers or something but two
things happen when you look at you okay
and I'm gonna shock my audience a little
bit cuz this is this is the real me I do
swear a little bit I don't swear a ton
but it throws people off so but I watch
the show and there's a lot of swearing I
mean and you guys just look at it as
like normal radio right but I'm very
I've been very cautious my entire right
especially entertainment career cuz my
kids I don't get back on the subject was
tell about my kids I just wanted to set
a good example for my I was doing that
even as a five I should say like a 15 18
year old I never drank and part of it I
think is because I've never done any
drugs and every day anything and it was
a lot of control but I also wanted to
tell my kids hey I never did any of this
stuff and now especially that's the easy
stuff and we had a lot of addiction of
addiction issues in my family and I'm
totally I've incredibly addictive
personality so I wanted to learn to do
like one or two impressions and I ended
up that's all people know me for at this
point so there's that but my kids I
didn't swear anything in am i specials
and stuff and now my kids talk like that
they're sailors their like my son looks
like he's in the middle of The Sopranos
he's 14 oh yeah what do you think he's
doing right now in your bedrooms frankly
scripts
watching pornos I'm you to think about
that I know it's 14 piece 14 and I was
dry humping little New Yorker reason
right matter it wouldn't fly come on let
me just believe he's playing xbox but
yeah he's just at you know it's it's
like unbelievable you doc you the first
time yes
like I don't like it but it totally this
is what happened to me I like I spent
all this time being clean
and safe and your this guy what was I
doing so to bring it back a little bit
where I'd started you're gonna have to
corral me in a bunch because this is
just what happened you have two things
going on one of them is I look at you
and I'm scared shitless because you have
that look but at the same time I look at
you and I want to laugh and I don't know
it's those two things that make you
great when I watch because if you smile
and other sudden it changes you go from
Joey you know from Joey to uncle Joey
Joey it's a it's so chavita watch around
I'm going from trust and mistrust how
many children do you have - my daughter
is 12 how was her mouth uh she's getting
there she's oh oh yeah cuz my wife my
wife liked my wife will teach them the
words and yeah because she's like I want
them to use them properly she's Italian
100% Italian so she's she's pretty much
Carmela soprano and she screwed up with
me you know that means she married the
wrong guy but she's she grew up in
Italian household and it's the real deal
yelling yeah her dad federal agent kind
of thing oh yeah big like the real know
were you from originally
I I'm from Chicago okay but I grew up in
Milwaukee so she calls my family
completely watered down at least the me
part of it a hundred percent of the
Italian I was telling Mike Rappaport
went up to Milwaukee in 98 to do I was
not required I listened to that and the
neighborhood right there when you walk
out of a comedy club you walk down to
the corner and you just hit the Italian
neighborhood in that bar where the
waitresses and waiters were they had the
owner had just got out of jail cuz
Donnie Brasco put him in jail right
because that neighborhood was very the
Ballesteros so the mob is up there I
mean there's Italian people up there
what happened to you was the Sun didn't
hit you right there's no Sun up there if
you would have been raised in Jersey or
somewhere with Sun like IRAs older now
the Italian should start Carbonari
you people are like a [ __ ] boot
in Sicily yeah look at me you folks I'm
the widest personal but uh no I thought
you were always from like Philadelphia
now shake shake Aparna Chicago Elmwood
Park Illinois right outside Chicago
great born is born in Cook County and I
grew up in Waukesha Ryan what 13 miles
west of Milwaukee suburban and normal
what did dad do he worked for the
caloric Corporation which was arranges
you know stoves and microwaves and stuff
like that then they merged with the man
he lost his job when I was a junior in
high school and he went back to
counseling and teaching when he was
younger he's a minor league baseball
player so we played sports all growing
up but when he lost his when he lost his
job that was one of those moments and
I've heard even heard this like in the
Jim Carey story where he talks about
well you never nothin's ever yet the
safest job in the world and then it was
just gone
and he had to go find something else to
why not take your chances and do
whatever you want in life because you
only have that you know you've those
chances do it while you're young so I
start I tried in comedy after when I got
into college I was in college I was
before I go to college university
Wisconsin Milwaukee no [ __ ] you stayed
at home yeah yeah listen man it's like a
lot of my life is just settling which is
a problem like I said I get happy I get
comfortable and then I don't work to get
to the next thing and that's that's
followed by another period in my life
where I'll just commit to my whatever
the craft is at the time or what I'm
working right now it's trying to develop
just develop not due to development but
try to develop outside of just doing
impressions and having people care
because when I get up on the stage the
first thing people are looking for is
for me to start doing any impression at
all when they hear my voice they're like
okay this is great but it's like carrot
top having his luggage get lost by the
airline or Jeff Dunham going out without
the puppets people are like okay so you
have to kind of
get them into you first before you get
into your you know mains like what they
know you for otherwise they're not even
gonna listen to it when I first started
doing stand-up like let's say I get up
there and just start doing my Tony Danza
breasts like John gage debate they'll
bode I would start doing that without me
ever talking and nobody would listen to
me in the show they would just wait for
the next impression so I started to
learn there has to be a little bit of me
up top I heard I heard you talk about
one show about how you would go and talk
about the city a little bit and you know
get people involved that way to me it
was to talk about a little bit about
myself so they'd see me and then I lost
that for a while because the money was
coming in all from the impressions so I
just went to that and and went for the
easiest way possible path of least
resistance and we'll just go up do
impressions right away and now I'm
working backwards again to try and find
people to give people the opportunity to
see a little bit of me here a little bit
of me and then pepper it with more of
the impressions there's almost like
exclamation points like I talked about
this with different people because like
Charles Barkley's always in the news
right he's always doing some good I
didn't I didn't I didn't see the police
concert any really yeah some of these
kind of and that right there it's easy I
don't boo me knuckle here you know it's
easy because you can turn something in
last last year Western Conference
semifinals I think it was draymond Green
on the Golden State Warriors one of
those guys if you love the team he's
your guy he's your Dennis Rodman if you
hate him he's your Dennis Rodman right I
can't stand this guy he's a tutor but
Charles Barkley his reaction to him was
honesty and truth he goes on TV and I
talked about this in my act he's like I
want to punch draymond Green in the face
and that's like I've never heard an
announcer do something like that that
sounds like an Italian announcer right I
won't push his guy in the face that was
gross so he says that but then he
apologizes later you know and I believe
they made him apologize and this is
gonna become something big if you don't
but he found a way to apologize because
he's always truthful and honest he found
a way to apologize that he could stay
true to himself and he basically went on
TV and said I apologize for recognizing
draymond Green has such a punchable face
which is not an apology but it's
brilliant because it sounds kind of like
an apology and it gets you out of it but
he stayed true to him and made is it's
basically a true cheat code in a video
game right he other people lose their
jobs he just got 20 extra lives but he
set himself up Berkeley set himself up
years ago as you know as an entity when
he was playing basketball he went out
said I am NOT a role model then he
constantly went out there improved it
and now he has a persona he gets to be
that guy and now you're set because you
have your point of view and people
that's Charles being Charles or that's
he's gonna be honest and it works and a
lot of what I've set up in my stage
presence over the years is well I'm
gonna put on a show for you and guys
like you go up there and some of the
people that I look to now and go how do
they do that you go out there and find a
way to have yourself go straight to the
audience and that's a key thing cuz you
can always be you might ramp something
up to be more for television or a movie
or something like that's a [ __ ] but you
might do it but it's still you when you
come here the first thing they say to
you is write jokes based on your sitcom
right so you could paint a picture for
the agents and the casting people and
the producers and the writers I thought
twenty comics that destroyed the career
by doing that in 98 to 2001 2002 they
were giving away those half-million
dollar deals right so people went from
going up there and saying I want to run
over a black guy in the car today
to going up there and talking about for
starters my little girl I picked her up
at school too when I saw it and I saw it
I saw the transformation of a lot of
comics in other words selling out all
right
selling out and then when they didn't
get nowhere with it they couldn't make a
comeback yeah they couldn't come back I
started as a one-liner guy I can't even
imagine the Rodney Dangerfield guy real
it's not gonna be a bit I'm not a ride
I'm not intelligent like you guys it's
not gonna be nothing and then
I heard a dear friend of mine then a
Showtime show and before he came on the
show I haven't go to the bathroom and
take a [ __ ] and I'm in the bathroom
taking a [ __ ] listen to them on Showtime
doing one-liners all right and I go
that's why nobody hires me all right
this is why I'm not this and this I go
up they start telling stories and if you
can come from truth that's it it was the
truth because people I don't know how
basal know it yes they smell weakness
they smell a lie you have to commit to
it it's like it's like an r-rated joke
when you're into comedy three years like
when I was doing comedy six years I came
up with this joke and I could not sell
the joke even though it made me laugh hi
and I'm hot I would kick on stage when
they said nobody else would laugh I
brought the junk back 13 years later it
destroyed because I wasn't ready for
that joke at there and I wasn't
presenting it right it's a dish with
it's like what you're saying with your
impersonations sometimes you just go up
there with a dish was taken on it right
it's a great steak a great steak I love
it what if you put little mashed
potatoes in the side three flowers for
orange slices raspberry it's a
presentation yes it's a present if they
know who you are and where you're coming
from they're coming they're coming
they're coming
I don't know what just fell but it
scared me no it was a drumstick I put up
there they just fell down okay clean the
place up this is cleaning up yeah thank
you
there's no drugs on the table we're how
to wipe it down because I was scared
that you went for a piss test next week
come back positive ketamine and heroin
in your system just touching it looks
like the wolf has been here no yeah we
clean everything here we try to put it
together with nobody I was listening to
wrap up the rope well the Rapaport show
too is funny cuz he was talking about
taking a dump before he came in yeah
yeah your bathrooms not connected it's
the perfect place to take yes all by
itself like that he should have done
that I was like a dump in there like
somebody else took it done you guys are
taking shits on the street
in Milwaukee were you thinking about
Comi then what were you thinking would
you look what ronnie has journalism okay
she would react I wanted to be a sports
center anchor okay you're a big sports
guy I'm not I people think I am now
again look at how tough a Green Bay
Packer food uh yeah it's a state law
basically you can't not although my
family's only you can't open up a club
in Green Bay
the funny woman used to be that they
died a thousand [ __ ] Appleton has a
small ax listen the first time I went to
Green Bay and as a comedian an adult
really because I've never gone up there
and Sundays everybody even the
McDonald's workers were wearing Brett
Favre jerseys it was I've never seen a
league like you gotta wear a McDonald's
uniform but not there I've never seen
anything like it but the whole city
shuts down the it's not a city it's a
town but the whole town whatever you
want to call the Green Bay Area I don't
know if it's still like that but this is
probably mid-90s - mm nothing a Packer
game is going on screw it you gotta get
you on a Sunday when I lived in Denver
those Sundays you could rob a bank yeah
you can send your mighty body that's
part I'm gonna forget when I was in the
wait a second I think you did have an
issue there I had a couple issues that
go to Colorado anymore I go to death oh
yeah I just wanna go to Seattle okay
Seattle and parts of argue see how the
parts I denote when I lived in Denver I
remember when they played against the
Cleveland Browns Drive right I was at
the mall during the drive and I'll never
forget the scene everybody in the
hallways watching TVs at RadioShack had
and stuff and going if I was gonna rob
this place this is the time I would do
it nobody would care the funny thing is
I would say something like that it's a
joke you say something like that you're
casing the place
oh I've been I cased I don't the best
thing in my future that happens that
they tore that mall down when I tell you
I sank that morale financially I'm not
worried I wanted there were three credit
cards in the summer of 85 and threw the
cards away and would still go back in
there
I remember walking in that mall one day
and they had a CD player
Radio Shack without a box like to say
units play unit and the guys are all the
way in the back talking and I go you
know what I could use a CD player in my
ass I'll never forget unplugging it and
just wrap it and walking out of the
[ __ ] mall like still walking 30 yards
to the door and then go into my car I
destroyed that more the first time then
I got a job at footlocker you got a job
at the mall after I ruined it with
credit cards and the cops came they go
you look you fit the description
somebody in the ice cream court said you
used a credit card there I'm like you're
gonna have to prove it there was no
cameras back there so they kept coming
back so you're wearing the the referee
Jersey rocker like an [ __ ] that I was
they I apply for the job in June they
called me in August okay okay we wanna
actually talking like three times and
they wanted me to cop to it I wouldn't
cop to it so in two months you destroyed
them all that's in once I destroyed that
[ __ ] one then I went back for more
then I went back I went to ask him back
to Boulder and then I was going taking
classes at the University of Colorado
and they would buy anything up on the
beach it's called the Youth EU disse
that the U District is in Seattle this
was called I forget what the folder
he'll or what the hell the hell is three
blocks gyms Mexican restaurants
everything is catered the kids pizza
place movie theater 18 and over bar that
type of [ __ ] but they would buy anything
because college kids got broke all right
so you could bring anything so I had to
scam it sees the door was right by the
music department was right by the door
I would park right there it's just
walking and every day I would take the
Bruce Springsteen for a package
collection it was like the hitless it
was 99 bucks like 89 bucks for a Bruce
Springsteen box he's on the cover with a
guitar in his hand how do I remember
because Bruce Springsteen put a lot of
money in my pocket plays a Bruce
Springsteen five at a time and I would
pick him up and walk out there
and I would go right through the hill
get my $200 and I go eat like a [ __ ]
sandwich is up it was destruction but
then I was out on bail on the kidnapped
I was running out of money and I go you
know what I'm gonna go back up to the CD
store so I started robbing them every
other day for about a week or two not
many people can just say that sentence I
started robbing to see these story other
dad I didn't want to be a [ __ ] pig
every two or three days I was tormenting
them because they would buy books like
in the hand and I would just pick up a
stack of books
I wouldn't even walk in the front door I
just bring them up and I got my mother
got minis but I already got a machine
I've been thinking and they go do you
want cash or a check you know what I
don't need the cash but I'll take it and
they would give you back the money for
the books bluestacks what's it like to
not have a conscience greatest life your
life is incredible until you get caught
what but then you have the stories what
is it that you want me to do to change
that like that's why it pisses me off
that people go after governor's for
putting blackface on or the chief
[ __ ] judge cuz he covered some chicks
mouth in 1982 you don't know where to go
so if he woulda came out and said yeah
1982 I took the girl because it works in
life that way if you don't say it if I
get it out first you got nowhere that
helps that can help God know where to go
eight mile when the two when he goes
what am I gonna do what he goofs on you
about the girl because if you put it out
there first he's got nowhere to go
right yeah cuz the you it defuses the
situation you watch Trump he'll be like
I did this in it and he'll put a little
spin on us to make it my you know his
way it happened there was a lot it was
not my problem yep and then people are
like yeah yeah he did it so what it's
not who I am today but thinking back it
will that person was that would be out
on bail for kidnapping and would go
every other day to either the Student
Center like one day I went to the
student suddenly had a watch track with
watches Timex whatever the [ __ ]
I picked up the whole thing and put it
on my shoulder like a body in Vietnam
and I just walked out if you're gonna
let me rob but you're not gonna pay
attention to me I gotta rob you in those
days how was that nuts in Boulder
yeah that's crazy but you're getting
away with it so why would you stop
getting away I would control myself yes
not controlling what do you think
control yourself this dog I would rob
24/7 double espresso machines came on 95
I was a struggling comic I don't even
buy Jess this because you're going into
stories about the stealing 24/7 and then
I remember with double shows yeah
because I lacked control before I got
arrested you get the prison had at no
control like that's when I got caught so
I'm out on bail for the kidnapping I get
caught with like 85 [ __ ] CDs and they
chase me like a little black guy in a
golf cart and a little white skinny guy
like come back and I'm running throwing
CDs back out [ __ ] trying to throw him
off like you're a superhero my god they
got me the cops finally got me and I
gave him a fake name they arrested me
and I processed now I just been in there
for a month waiting to get bail every
cop new Joey I went in there is Jimmy
and they're fingerprinted me and I'm
like how you doing and I'm looking at
the fingerprint card it's like Jimmy
whatever I'm like these guys if you have
you gonna be that stupid and then I went
back to court as that guy I pled guilty
and I got community service and I did
the community service years later I
found that ball defy on that you used a
different name what do you need the
community service you paid the fine
crazy [ __ ] that you would even now you
can't just say now there's no way you're
not that's all electronic yeah they get
away with but that's yeah I mean you
make me want to go back in time and
start robbing people and then in those
days remember with Frank Caliendo put
his fingerprints there and see is was so
slow right three weeks before your
records came back so you could sit in
County for two weeks with a murder no
one working your bail and get out before
their NCIS come out back on you and NCIS
wouldn't come back on you for [ __ ]
three [ __ ] weeks
that's how slow was that
like to use fake names I could do all
this [ __ ] because by the time they
figured out who the [ __ ] I really was I
was gone I was on I was on a Greyhound
bus to the next city so what did he do
with the espresso machines
well the expresso machine I had me I had
control the expression machines were
$450 you keep saying you have
controllers I mean is this you telling
us are you trying to complete convince
yourself I don't give a [ __ ] it was 25
years ago
Yeah right no yeah it was 25 so I was 95
I forgot most pressing machines or how
this story started it was $450 for an
expresso coffee cappuccino machine all
these [ __ ] gonna sail the 350 I'm
walking into those stores just picking
up the thing I wasn't even walking out
of the store frequently enough how sad
is that I would just go into customer
service and behind door my mother got me
this for Christmas
[ __ ] okay it's always somebody giving
you something yeah well you could sell
it that's how you do it I was walking
down the street I don't have a gift for
sheep but then I got been here on for
the point where I'd hang out in front of
camera this is what you're a [ __ ]
real piece of [ __ ] and hang out for the
came on our windy days and waiver
people's receipts to fly over and one
day I'm looking at this guy in the cart
pushing two by fours and two by sixes
the two by [ __ ] twelves but on top
he's got a lot more he's pushing it's
windy out and awesome the receipt flora
I go if I pick it up I looked alone
Morris 450 so I walk into the [ __ ]
Kmart they got no more lawnmowers like a
[ __ ] I want a Longmont Colorado 30
miles away went to it came on in there
they had to think the best was I went
back then I gave the Mexican can attend
bring this up to the counter for me he
brought it up to the counter and I told
the lady how you doing my mother gave me
this this time I had a receipt this time
they had nowhere to go I'm telling
I bought it why don't you go back to
Boulder I go I didn't want to drive I
live here I left this here and they give
me the money but I can't it's it's it's
and I was doing three or four those
expression machines a day like on the
way to Denver calmly were needed the
espresso sausages they would stop in
Westminster
I'd stop in the Denver mall I
would show up at the cotta Comedy Works
at 1200 in my pocket on the way there
it's like the Comedy Works open mic
start at 8 I leave my house at 6 and
stop in Bloomfield Westminster and you
stop at the malls I need money you use
all this stuff when you play these roles
do you use all the stuff that you've
done what's in my mind right yeah never
leaves my mind I don't I've never put it
away I did it I gotta own up to it right
but you can use that when you play a
character you can use that those
memories to be dr. Eric yeah absolutely
that's what I do and I have an audition
I look at it I give the guy a fake name
like if you call me you know I want you
to play Frank Wright I make him Frank
Luigi I give a background on him born in
the Bronx his father [ __ ] worked on
shoes his mother was a Sicilian
immigrant and I just write out his
background right he started he's a loan
shark today but he started out running
errands for and Zelda Baker I just make
up [ __ ] right that's the background but
I can't have that story and it meant
everything like sex Harry yeah now how
long did it take after college to Trice
did you get a job broadcasting uh no
because I didn't want to work and like
Oh Cara Claire Wisconsin there's
something like that being a I was
terrible as an interviewer I always
wanted to be a guest on like The Tonight
Show and stuff like that I want to be
the person being interviewed I was loved
those comedians that would go on their
old school be like a Jonathan winters or
even people promoting movies Robin
Williams or something like that's what I
wanted to beat was just a guest on a
late night show but I went I I graduated
from college I tried stand-up one time
it was a night at a dance club and
they'd shut the dancing down for a
comedy and music show to be played and
yeah people want to dance
kokin [ __ ] yeah it was it was unbuttoned
Williams impression I'm like hum Robin
Williams nothing I go no I'm not
and it was the saddest I was bearded
Robin Williams in like awakenings or
something with just like oh this isn't
working at all and I thought it was me
and it probably was partially me not
ready to do that kind of event because I
was supposed to be the host of it but
as you know comedy have to do comedy in
a venue that people are expecting comedy
and I later learn that and use these
types of experiences to just say no to
other gigs as they came along at the
beginning you take a lot of things that
you probably shouldn't but you also
learn from that in some ways but you
know things are gonna suck and then you
get to a certain point you go I'm just
not taking those sucky you know gigs
anymore but then I went I graduated from
college and I started to I actually got
hurt I hurt my back and believed in I
was from tying my shoe I leaned down to
tie my shoe and my back went out and
then I couldn't stand up straight for
like a month so I started working on a
bunch of impressions and then I went up
at a comedy club the comedy cafe which
was run by JD you see what happened that
I may be the mob got him though I heard
he had a stroke oh well that's the last
I heard
cuz he's older the other stroke there
was nothing like he was the nicest guy
in the world to me big Samoan guy but
thought he was at a 7 yeah 400 would
take you to eat on Thursday and when he
paid when he pays a gun other briefcase
and a gun would go up there hey you
ready for this like worried for what how
many times did you work for it Oh tons
he what gave me work all he was the
first person ever gave give me work gave
me work all the time he's like you he'd
say stuff like how much time ago how
much break how much trouble you got I'd
be like like three minutes five minutes
he goes I'll tell you what we'll put you
up steal a bunch of stuff and go up to
him like I'm not gonna
he's like we'll figure something out
you're dead you're killing with the
crowd because I just go up and do
impressions and nobody was doing that at
the time he's like you come back next
week well then I then I was I'd hurt my
back got sick for a while was out and I
come back a year later as it were you
boom I was like I was hurt he's like I
don't care get back up there and he
started working me again I mean this is
literally the second and third time I've
been up on stage and he's just putting
me to work and I get to work with some
cool people coming through well he was
this this is probably 90 the first time
was probably 95 a graduated college 96
95 ish and then back in 96 I think
somewhere you had your back that bad
yeah I couldn't I couldn't do it I
couldn't get out of bed just in time
your shoelace I always say that I had a
knee injury when I was younger and when
I was 14 I destroyed my knee we were
playing I was a running back in flip on
the same size now that I was then maybe
20 pounds lighter but I was pretty fast
and for you know a suburban high school
freshman team they couldn't they
couldn't tackle me so but I was running
out was we're plep scrimmaging the
sophomores I ran a sweep to the right
and I get hit by a guy and a guy low and
my knee just buckled and went out and it
never really recovered so I would I was
also a catcher in baseball and I would
catch off kilter I would catch with one
leg fully bent and my left leg which was
destroyed would never wouldn't Bend all
the way and it screwed up my back so
then back issues happened for the rest
of my life so this is five six years
later I'm could be doing anything and my
back just went out and that just
happened really bad one time when I was
a freshman sophomore in college
somewhere in there must have been yeah
must been soft junior year probably
junior year and I was just out for a why
couldn't do anything I was just I
couldn't go to school I couldn't I
couldn't physically couldn't get up out
of bed because I couldn't walk and that
was at least two weeks and then it took
some more time prime milked it some
after a little while like then you get
scared about going back cause you missed
a month you know two weeks of college
what I'm gonna do but I was doing all
the work at the time there wasn't even
email or anything like that I was just
having to call people and get the work
and I think they they liked that enough
that I was taking the initiative to do
that that you know I got through and
made it you know work with the teachers
and I think I probably got A's in the
classes broadcasting journalism classes
aren't that hard it's not like I'm doing
physics or something so then when I came
back after college cuz I just said you
know I'm gonna get my degree right now I
got it just because that's what you do
not for any other reason other than that
and then I uh and then I went back out
and I started working right away people
to start paying me to do stand-up I got
on the college circuit in a year because
I'm 24 years old 20 and 23 years old and
at that point
colleges that was experimental to now
you do a college they don't want you to
say anything back then you could get
away with whatever and I even say get
away I don't mean get away with it was
just a time to speak freely and say what
you thought and now it's the the speech
police at colleges it's ridiculous I can
ask you a question that's the point I
chose as a young man were you privy to
impressions like were you already
getting from the family what all that
all that just just that you know we gift
I think I always did some of it as a
high school student I would do
impressions of friends and stuff
oh and teachers we had a teacher mr.
Christiansen who's he was also the
basketball coach like mr. Kelly and oh
do me a favor can you come up and show
us on the map where the Atlantic Ocean
is and I'd go up there and be like an
idiot I'm like was it the blue part you
know any other be like go sit down and
it would be kind of mess with me because
I didn't know anything about geography
but there was this guy Darren Marsh who
like he he always had the the comb in
his back pocket and he feather his hair
and his nostrils with flare so I do
impressions of him and a couple other
people and watch Saturday Night Live and
in living color and do all the Damon
Wayans characters of you know that kind
of thing or the fire marshal but let me
show you I thought that so I'm doing all
those things stuff you wouldn't use in
your stand-up back because it's somebody
else's character and then I started
working on nobody was doing impressions
of people how they actually are people
were doing impressions of characters in
movies so I would do the Robin Williams
where you'd be the serious Robin
Williams in your Toa story you know that
kind of thing or Tony Danza like and I'd
find things that were observational
comedy with them Tony Danza the bit was
he would talk normally pretty much until
somebody from the old neighborhood came
around right so it was like on who's the
boss jaw did sebade the mole de and then
like his acting chops were like just to
go a hundred percent to the old school
the old big character and it was just to
me that was the funny observation in it
and there was an offbeat oppression the
people were only doing Jack Nick
I'll sit at the time nobody was really
like now it's Christopher Walken like
that right Chris Jack Nicholson was the
one everybody was doing and they were
doing these big over-the-top Jack
Nicholson's and I would do just a
silence at quiet one you know that the
more real guy and people like well
that's a different version and even
people who hated impressions were like
you're actually kind of doing something
a little bit different so comics like me
because I developed an act like most
comics would see an impressionist and go
this guy sucks you mean you look at
YouTube now and like people do way
better impressions than me I see people
like doing these incredible oppressions
but they don't create a character with
it that much and you go after they do
the line you're kind of going okay now
what what what how did where does this
go and even with you know the old-school
stuff I do like John Madden I got bored
with doing the you know at the John man
I turned him into a character let's go
and make these big noises and it became
this its own character as opposed to
just the impression to me that became
more fun and there were people who could
do dead-on impressions better than me
but I would find the physicality and
stuff like that to go with it and what
I'm trying to do now in my act and life
and everything is doing that with
characters you you you you just put a
voice to something that happens in your
life and that's almost like you an
impression is just a character that
everybody knows already a character you
have to set up more and give people the
background cuz they don't know what the
point of view is on the character I had
an uncle Uncle Phil that was manin I
think he I think you and him would have
been great friends but he had this whole
thing about like he hey Frankie you
should spend time with Shane actress
like really can't tell you but here's
your story like you get you stole me
can't tell me a story like at one point
he was the cheese king of Chicago he's
like you can't friend any get mad about
I don't even understand it you Frankie
you can't get cheese and Chicago we're
not going to me I'm like what what's
house trying to get the cheese what are
you worried about like what's
are there other cheese gurus out there
so I was like that kind of stuff
those guys into characters and and make
that part of my act and be part of what
I'm trying to become and tell the
stories but its truth again it goes back
to that truth stuff that Who am I and
what's my background I tell stories
about that stuff and people go go crate
you can you can look him up because he
was gone for a while but he I don't even
know if I should be saying this but he
quit witness protection I've never seen
anybody do that but he all of a sudden
we had Italian Christmas you know on the
phone hey it's Uncle Phil hey Frankie
aid you know where are you can't shake
and then one year he just showed up
again or like what how is he here yeah
it's aliens kids oh they'll go block the
windows shut the shuttle leave everybody
duck we're gonna have a lo Christmas
when did you think about that way when
did you start thinking about that way
that somebody reach out to you ah yes a
manager did and he said I don't want to
use names you probably know him but he's
like you gonna comb out here man it'll
be incredible so I get I couldn't even
get on make me laugh I couldn't get on
the show make me laugh that's when I
first came to LA make me laugh was with
the kid that no no make me laugh was all
comedians would go on and just tell
jokes to a person sitting there ah he's
in Vegas now doing the revivalism way
and somebody and because what happened
can we take the thousands of [ __ ]
episode yeah I don't even remember who
it ain't me laugh a little Jewish kid I
don't he was a host nice kid real nice
would be at The Improv every night but
the people who did really great weren't
joke because some people go on and tell
jokes and some people would go on and
just say goofy things and do goofy right
the whole part of a joke is that people
kind have to know when the joke is
coming so they know when to laugh :
Bobby van that's what Mark Cohen says
right so so the people who was what's
his name who's I find him incredibly
hilarious Todd oh ass yeah Todd glass
eyes glass would do well Todd glass was
a guy who would just kill on there look
at me yeah I remember it was
the stuff that really made you like cuz
you don't know what's coming a point of
a joke is you might not know what the
joke is but you know when it's coming
it's an assumption that's set up and
then you Zig when you think you're gonna
zag and that's where the funny part
comes from they like you get caught off
guard and people put two and two
together in their heads and they go I
got it so that I couldn't even get on
that show and everybody was on that show
make me laugh almost everybody was done
everybody was everybody minus two X
minus two was on that show now what was
your first show that you got out of
there uh I think they got me he got me
in Craig Kilborn I think Craig Kilborn
improv show did you go I never did an
improv show
well what what shown before MADtv you
are hype on The WB hype okay hype was I
got a sketch show it bribe scum I got
that and that was in the chicken deal
chicken who went to Montreal he got a
huge one of the like you talked about
earlier in the episode the 500 he was
the last surgery because they kind of
figured out that they were getting
played by the agents and managers in
Montreal for the people who don't know
the Montreal Comedy Festival before the
internet was where people got discovered
a lot of comedians so you go on and you
do these new faces and I remember going
on like doing my I was doing a gala set
which was one of those bigger shows and
Chelsea Handler was going to do the new
faces and I was just I was basically
just mocking her the whole time cuz she
was so into herself and like just like
what's where's this girl where's this
woman ever gonna end up and now she's
huge right but it was one of those kinds
of things like going wow she's really
determined to sell herself and be
important I'm like I'm the total
opposite I'm kind of just a joke just
who got lucky and got here but uh those
new faces he got a $500 deal by humping
a stool right if I went five hundred
thousand dollars and Mitch Hedberg the
year before it gotten a huge deal too
and so there was this there was this
whole thing of people getting these five
hundred thousand dollar th Hedberg got
the deal when they came this is how
different the time was when they came
back they closed the improv on Monday
and Tuesday night
monday was a showcase for riders and
Tuesday was a showcase for show runners
hmm that's how different the industry
was they don't even do showcases missed
out no more or they don't I don't see a
showcase a PA used to do a big showcase
but you need it you can just see
everybody yeah nobody's gonna come you
can just [ __ ] different internet just
changed all that so so the chicken deal
what happened was he was really he had a
great presence but he was just humping
his tool and they made it so nobody
could get into there that was brilliant
brilliantly done by agents and managers
was it was nobody get it and all the
networks were bidding on this guy that
nobody knew and didn't even know what he
did because they weren't so there was no
internet so you couldn't research what
he was doing piers is like somebody
wants him we got to have him and then
they had a deal Warner Brothers gave him
a deal and didn't know what show to put
him in
so they merged him with my deal in my
show and it became the show called hype
and it wasn't right for him at all but
he got on xxx he was in that and he had
some he had some real heat but we had a
show that was a weird thing arm show
runners were going for massages during
the day when they should have been show
running it was this kind of a mess there
were some very talented people it was
just it wanted to be a pop culture
cheesy show because it was WB and it
should have been a gritty more real
which was what was gonna they didn't see
the future like the Chappelle and
everybody going in and having filmed
pieces that weren't jokey jokes they
were more situational stuff and we're
doing these big jokey line stuff to the
camera it was like hee-haw or something
like that for people remember that can
you just tell a joke and as you know
like you were talking about earlier with
your act one-liners yeah you might have
a great one-liner but people are gonna
say look they might not even remember
the one line your personality they'll go
he's the guy who sells the espresso
machines without ever buying them it's
like people remember that stuff and they
remember the situation and the person
they what was the girl or am i their -
their Shaima Tosh who is there was
another well there are three of there
was Gemma Tosh Kristen Nelson and Nadya
Ginsburg
and
I think that's Brian how long did pipe
it was like 12 episode then they
remembered that because it was if they
started out its high tonight on The WB
and three weeks later the WB Sunday he'd
like they've gotten rid of hike night
and just went to the WB Sunday because
that was a I remember I used to host it
to storm one Sunday night Lewis II cake
him and know we was right and I said you
only go up because yeah I am I put him
up and as he walked out he was hey I got
a show for you you went down this week
and at that time they had the Cedric the
Entertainer variety should I remember
that sketch I think they were on oh
maybe they were doing that when I was at
MADtv I was on the same lot as they
might be or something like that and then
when did you get it so how far after
hype did you get on MADtv uh right uh
right away afterward cuz that show got
canceled
and then when I first went to LA -
another thing was I went in and met with
the president of NBC at the time and he
goes do you want me to put you on
Saturday Night Live I'm like it would be
an option and then we got out of the
room and the manager goes you said it'll
be an option when did you say then I'm
like because you told me never to show
my carts and I was like he's like yeah
but I didn't think you'd do something
like that everybody says yes I'm like
well you just have to be like you in
control I never did I did because it was
the president of NBC and I had heard
stories about like Jim Breuer and stuff
like that where the the-- the network
tried to put you on there and you had a
terrible time because they want to find
you and they had Darrell Hammond I
wasn't gonna do sit behind Darrell
Hammond for years and be the second guy
so when the MADtv think came along I
just took that when I was doing
auditions in LA when I first came out
here when I couldn't get on make me
laugh they started having me do
auditions for some sketch shows MADtv
wanted me I'd go in there I did a thing
called the five minutes of fury and I
don't know how long it was I don't know
why we call that that but it was just
impression after impression after
impression and one after another
nobody's doing a price of time I'd leave
a room and people would want they just
want to give me development deals that's
all I got the WB deal that they merged
with chicken it's the Michael roof it's
they
I would do this stuff and I go in for a
commercial audition or something like
that and I just do that and they would
they would want to call back and I would
suck at the commercial and they just
want to hear you know what you do so uh
I I went in did did that where were we
going with that I'm sorry I lost my
train of thought go to MADtv Oh mad seat
so I went back after hike was canceled
they just put me on MADtv I never
audition season was that like six oh no
I was down aways I mean it was probably
yeah yeah seven or eight somewhere in
yeah it started not even know cuz I'm
six maybe seven yeah cuz Artie Lange was
there for a couple years he was the
faculty that will sasso ya Cowen who's
counting nervous breakdown I did
spider-man with her nice hundred
ninety-five nice young black I remember
the first show was the first host was
Rosa had bought of MADtv no right and
Doug Stanhope was supposed to do
stand-up on it oh really I don't the
original pilot or something like that I
don't know we think that was something
different it was something different
yeah because they had that Saturday
night special well he he's uh he's high
he's Heights to think so that where is
he I don't know but I don't listen I
came up in the colleges I never was
around everybody everybody's doing sets
with each other like The Improv and
stuff like that or at the Laugh Factory
I never did any of that stuff I never
did the that's part of my problem in the
podcast world you know everybody knows
each other and they go on each other
show that's why I really appreciate you
having me on to is like everybody know I
don't know anybody I don't it's not
because I was a jerk or anything no
maybe no maybe I could have been but it
was more that I just didn't know anybody
cuz I was always isolated and kind of
shy to try and get myself onto stuff and
so I've back-to-back Trek that satellite
special show was on they found out that
MADtv was doing better than that
Saturday night special thing
MADtv went on and was on for thirteen
fourteen years whatever it was and they
were on a crazy contract that like they
didn't have to pay you real money
because it was late night Fox and there
was nothing else in that world so that
you like the money you'd make on that
show which sounds like a lot to the
regular
person who's not in entertainment but
that's like $5,000 in episode you're
making there and you might only get in
seven episodes the first year so you
know a sitcom you small I would have
gone crazy
I'm [ __ ] with a staff through
somebody would have done a real [ __ ]
got real brothers to beat them up
African I don't know because racial
probably not money for it yeah you're
right you're mm you can finally yeah so
Hollywood a nickel in those days go by
but you couldn't go by yum yum donuts on
Santa Monica but think because don't
care for big black [ __ ] to beat you
up over that remember I used to be
[ __ ] rode down there I got a
[ __ ] yeah you make that turn
right into there then that was that was
the set right there or that was where
that stalks well yeah well uh it was I
can't remember the name but the funny
thing is they do Disney shows there cuz
it was really Hollywood Center studios
and it's like Disney like The Suite Life
with Zack & Cody would record their
cedric the entertainer and MADtv and it
used to be back in the day it was
Lucille Ball oh do you look like you
could have been a great I went in for a
couple of auditions let me tell you
something I went to that last issue the
lot is the one you're supposed to turn
left into if you coming from Sunset
mm-hmm there's sometimes a line and
sometimes they'll tell you you know you
don't belong a lot make a u-turn and go
to the corner right and one day and I
was [ __ ] drinking all night
snorting doing god knows what type of
pills I hate I think God knows what the
been like five and I pulled up into a
lot to do somebody's show wasn't yours
with so many officers she could have
been mine you'd have been good at and I
pulled in the guy goes you out the park
all the way down there I go dog there's
a parking spot that was 400 pounds I go
I'm not walking out of there so I pulled
into the spot when I came out he ran up
to me and he's like I just [ __ ] told
you what to do when I go what you say
I'm like an elbow I was the night before
I got him with his shoveled it to the
face he went back don't you ever [ __ ]
tell me where to park your [ __ ] and as I
walked he was yelling at me when I got
back to the set they're like what
happened
and I had just gotten fired from the man
show wait you got nobody could get fired
from the man show yeah I did OK ROCK
yeah
the pilot episode I caught the director
lifer got Rogan did now I caught the
director lying and I've told them out in
the hallway I heard what you did
[ __ ] I'm gonna tell John would
stand up because you're fired
I go [ __ ] you and then they made the
security guard escort me off but I'd
smoke the joint with the security guard
two hours earlier he's like that's my
dog ain't throwing him out of here [ __ ]
him tremendous you can't write this [ __ ]
Franco no you can't I can't even believe
you've lived it but I yeah I showed the
guy and like the [ __ ] throw he went
down like the John Jones move well you
yeah he was like what the [ __ ] you crazy
don't tell me what a park I asked you
[ __ ] nicely if you save enough one of
your friends just [ __ ] I love that in
your mind I asked you [ __ ] nice yes
you [ __ ] means I can do [ __ ] I
just had knee surgery my back is out my
grandmother died necessary to walk all
the way over [ __ ] that when I could
park right there he gave me like a
little bit of an attitude psycho it's me
against him there's nobody else on just
watch no care no cameras at that temple
in there I pulled I had my bag you know
you have to bring wardrobe yeah a
wardrobe I'm like I'm not walking from
over that's what happened how much is
your life changed because of the camera
like think about with cameras being
everything very much I wonder how much
that truly affected you like you like
you let me ask you this and maybe I'm
completely wrong in this but it's like
you've changed and you said to having a
kid has changed you and stuff like that
but you had to change there's an element
to your life that couldn't exist anymore
right a pretty big element that might
have driven you to be hey I could be
this different part addition shoulder
the guy in December in New York New
Jersey just to put my daughter and my
wife in front of me because I had my
daughter by the hand Frank Caliendo
I was on line like a gentleman my wife
was standing behind me and we were all
talking and also the guy caught and
bounced me and I looked at him and as he
came this way my daughter was right here
in my right hand
you're not gonna bang into my door
yeah so I hit him with the shoulder he
[ __ ] went back and I go is there a
[ __ ] prom and he stand me down a
little bit it's not there's no problem
and I wait and I didn't take my eyes off
didn't take my eyes off and he kept
staring at me they go you sure there's
no [ __ ] power it'll take care of this
right now he goes not as my we both were
on the ferry and I thought he was gonna
jab me on the way off the ferry in
Jersey
I watched him get off and I had my phone
right it was a smash right in his
[ __ ] head there's something that
family thing I remember of my family
you're not gonna do that I would [ __ ]
kill you yeah you're gonna die right
here on the spot you gave me a like a
flashback to something with my grandpa
yeah I remember being in a Chucky Cheese
when I was maybe eight years old or
something is in Chicago in a Chucky
Cheese I'm playing defender or something
some old video game and I step aside
some other bigger kid steps and starts
playing my game and I'm like what just
happened my grandpa's there and he's
like what happened Frankie and I'm like
this guy started playing my game my
grandpa my grandpa the little Italian
guy but all of a sudden he's Joe Pesci
right and I don't do a good job
prescient president he picked the guy up
and just said don't ever do that to my
grants like forever I was on like I was
scared to death but also like I got the
right guy yeah I got the right guy get
the right fan but he picked him up and
like just my grandson I was like holy
cow what blood do I have a different
world rank it was you know we live in a
world now that especially they're like
you ever been on the set the director
comes on with a hat with a feather
rolled up shirt so you could show you
Agel tattoo some [ __ ] American Eagle
like he's cool everybody's telling that
that too is cool
and they'll talk to you a certain way
right that wasn't gonna fly with me you
know how we call them on I'd say that's
not gonna happen I don't play that
[ __ ] Gentile [ __ ] go well that works
for kids in acting class don't talk to
me that way yeah I just met talk to me
like a man I always just find that I
just I don't find I don't believe
anything out here no no this is a
remember it's the world then it's Los
Angeles right our view why
Steen wouldn't happen never Neverland
you know you Jesse slow let these
[ __ ] mothers that paid a half a
million to get their kids in school
where does that happen
here in la-la land where that [ __ ]
wouldn't fly anywhere else I just
remember being lied to so much you know
live with us from from the beginning I
remember telling people telling me oh
this is gonna be the biggest thing for
you're gonna blow up like they tell you
that constantly and you're going what
wait a second I I didn't even do it that
wasn't good you asked me to do it again
yeah and they get your call it's called
getting caught up yeah they blow so much
smoke up your ass and then one day what
happens he end up like chicken yeah God
imagine the plight chicken imagine being
super faint mansion being LeBron James
when do you think the last time somebody
told him no was for it like there's not
a middle school it when you maybe was
big in high school yeah I mean nobody
taught just because they knew he was
going to be goober famous and then he
gets out here and how easy is it for him
to make a television show and I watched
LeBron James shows you ever watch some
of these shows oh but this is this is
what's funny about and this happens this
I'm sure happens with all the biggest
stars this is a LeBron James show ready
I agree with you LeBron no no no I agree
with you more LeBron like five guys just
agreeing with them like there's no way
he can get real answers there's nothing
like people just start I had it happen
to me for a while to as you start to go
up and you just people just start to
that's great you're like I just I took a
dump that just sucked that white tell me
that's correct
you're bad for a lot of comedic actors
especially on shitty TV shows they have
those PAS and that's what they get paid
to do where I've left right I'll fluff
on a set they suck your dick and get
your dick hard and keep your heart
that's what they do that was great
they blow smoke up your ass and then you
end up what's the kid who did that show
in Idaho that movie that he wore this
shirt he's my friend
what was that [ __ ] morons or was that
movie I don't know
came on was popular 15 years ago raising
in Idaho come on every [ __ ] body
right that and the kid came down here he
did a movie with Will Ferrell I'm not a
talking about
that guy had a zero talent that's comedy
zero but he did a movie and they all
sucked his dick and then he did that
will farm boy which will carry them and
then they gave his own show on Comedy
Central you heard what happened there no
I don't know no like even when Comedy
Central tells you you're bad you're bad
the point dynamically inside of my yeah
they blow smoke up your ass and then
what day you left in your beautiful John
Titor million dollar home and nobody's
hiring you right because that show at
seven years was worked for you
right but into real realm of things
you're not really that funny of a guy i
watch a lot of these shows and i don't
know what the [ __ ] that told well see
that's i always believed in stand-up as
if you had if you base your money your
career and stand up you always have
something to go back always I look and
make the money like you're gonna be you
can have ups and downs on TV a
television show there'll be times where
people think you're important and not
important but as long as you can sell
some tickets to a specific audience
you're fine and your your do the st.
you're the you're probably doing more
than me right now but you at a certain
point you learn that how to work that
system because a lot of times you go
into the comedy clubs or the theaters or
whatever you're doing and you just
expect you you accept an amount of money
they're gonna pay you like they'll come
in and say okay we'll pay you a grand
for the week that's awesome good Connie
make a living then you realize they're
selling tickets and they're making a lot
of money doing this I gotta be paid more
and when you're with the the agents but
then the agents and the managers they're
all tied in and a network to a certain
level where they there's give it some
slack and stuff like that but they let
things go and you're like I can make
more in this and like we can ask I know
you're gonna tell them because I'm a
draw right now you're like there's
nothing more powerful than the word no
in Hollywood all we said you say no all
of a sudden people like what wait and
then they want you ten times as much you
say no to something and people they
don't even understand that's half of my
meetings when I first came to LA I'm
like I don't know if I want to do that
they're like they don't even know how to
respond then all of a sudden they're
like we got to get this guy but
nobody there everybody's so desperate
yeah everybody's so desperate to do
something that they're they they feel
like you have this confidence of like
how I would go in with network
executives and just make fun of them
because everybody was so nervous with
the network executive I'd take the
chance I'm like hey what a 50/50 you
know it's probably a better chance
they're not gonna like me in the first
place anyways because they see so many
people let me just try and be myself and
be a jackass
I must I'm a smart aleck sarcastic a
little bit of a jerk well I may be it
and it's it's not not like a jerk to be
a jerk but just to be funny and get the
laugh out of it and I'll take the chance
but you go in there and you say Oh mr.
smiles I am have been working on this
Pete they don't they see that all the
time they see you nervous they feed on
that and they go and this isn't the
right person you go in there like what
what means you choose that tie and
they're like huh like look at your tie
you're a network executive you can't
wear that ethic you really don't like
the tie why not like your net you
shouldn't and they start going on back
there what are you doing what are you
doing you could try to do that real I
mean I could see you going into right go
into a room and take it over yeah I go
into a room and let him know I win the
choice it's like going to church it's a
new air all right I going in when we sit
on what happened to the good war this
what the [ __ ] and they're like he can
control the room you just sold the show
yeah you just sold the show did you hear
that's how uh what's his name for taxi
how Louise De Palma who played Danny
DeVito DeVito Danny DeVito went in there
and he was the louis de palma character
he was just a jackass like what is this
you know and they're like this is the
guy cuz you take a chance you go in
there and be safe if you're really
good-looking there's a chance maybe some
but there's a lot of good-looking people
you go in there and you do something
that's interesting or different than
everybody else now of a sudden they're
like who I went to a commercial audition
and I I wasn't right for the commercial
was all some computer or something and I
did that five minutes of fury thing I
talked about it was so stupid I'd like
to look back and think how embarrassing
it was to do that thing but they're like
I go and I had to sing or something like
that and improv the commercial which is
a whole nother thing it could get into
but they I go in and I'm like I am NOT
free
I gotta go I'd leave and I get a
callback for the commercial and I'm like
wait
hey agent said like they loved you I'm
like I didn't I didn't do the commercial
audition i said i don't feel it i said
i'll suck at this and i left there like
they want to see you tomorrow I'm like
I'm not going in because I'm not right
for it they're just saying that because
they feel like they want to be in power
and they want to tell me no we don't
want you that's what they wanted they
want to tell you no we don't want you
they don't want you to walk away on your
own power you know what somebody does it
like it's a breakup like it was a
relationship with the break-up really
quick where they're like we just think
what you can't I'm dumping you you're
not dumping me but I remember that that
was another thing I've learned on some
of these early commercial auditions they
go in and you you you improvise and then
you're the commercial without you like
they get people to come in and I just
play around with the product a little
bit and you do that and all of a sudden
saying wait a second that's my using it
as a cigar bit
it's that has nothing to do where did
that come from and you go I don't want
to write these coming tonight that's
part of my problem in LA - cos people
there's way better improvisers than me
and they all know what's gonna happen
but they some they eventually get some
of the stuff but again that's playing
off a lot of a desperateness in that
world I just couldn't auditions to me
and maybe you just have a better
self-worth than I do is it but you go in
and you're sitting on a bench and you're
sitting next to in a hallway and you're
just like wow I'm really groveling to
try and get this along with three other
people who are on sitcoms 15 years ago
first of all look how they see me like I
look like sloth from the Goonies and you
know these other three guys that are
here I look like that to them it's like
what I remember Harlan Williams Dane
Cook and like two other guys were always
at the same audition when I was pretty
hot when I first came to LA I would get
movie scripts sent to me that Jack Black
and two other fat guys turned down it
was like maybe Caliendo will look at
this and they didn't want me anyways but
they're just going down the script and
they found out I didn't have the pole to
have a movie made in the first place but
it was like wow that's that's who they
think I am I mean we ever go to an
audition you look around and go I look
exactly like
three of these other guys what am I
gonna do that's gonna be different and
if I don't have something I guess I'm
just like these three other guys than
the higher the guy who's tall and
better-looking I mean I went in for
daredevil I remember going in for dared
the original daredevil that was Ben
Affleck Africa and and and yeah right
and what was uh he's in he directs now
and he was in Rudy for a small bit he
was in elf he's happy in the an Iron Man
you'll know exactly Oh swing oh yeah Jon
Favreau Jon Favreau and Jon Favreau got
there I was never gonna get that part
Jon Favreau's gotten the part and like
you're going for these auditions and
it's like but every once in a while
somebody gets one of the agents ever
have an agent do this oh they can't wait
to see you they're really they really
when you go down there and they don't
even know who you are
it's worse it's the worst thing and I
always loved auditioning Frank III was
like as I wasn't making it as a comic
I'm the only personal light he was Mitzi
shore okay and Montreal wouldn't take me
they didn't like what I did with my hand
it was just a magnet so I grew up I'm an
immigrant I grew up on [ __ ] movies
Charles Bronson you know the Lord you
know fracking Dirty Harry you know I
grew up on an active Steve McQueen so
movies are always very intriguing to me
so when I came to town I wasn't ready
but I signed with a power television
manager if there was a project he gets
you in it he grew up in Hollywood he
grew up in Beverly Hills he knew
everybody so I went in four men in black
I'd go to all that [ __ ] that was one of
the many I never booked anything and
then I figured out I know what I'm good
at
my guy would start getting my mind
prepared but the main audition I never
liked that I still turned down today is
there we don't know what they're looking
for audition and then go [ __ ] your
mother
unless it's unless I can walk do it but
we don't know what we're looking for
audition you know unless we got that or
then I could walk through it I'll go if
I could walk to it but if that's if I
got to drive to Santa Monica
we don't know what we're looking for
audition coming to Jazz's coming with
three original characters and it's a
little you're looking for a writer [ __ ]
alright yeah actually you look that's
that how many auditions that I go in and
improvise and the next day I went to
shooting my line was it that's I'm
talking about what the commercials were
in there and I go what the [ __ ] is this
and you don't say nothing cuz you're
dumb you don't want to rock the boat
hey give me a writing credits up yeah an
associate to the associate the associate
for this is the stories but I enjoyed
auditioning because after a while I
would go in there
I started getting popular with auditions
and I'm not scared to say this because
of The Sopranos and I look like one of
the guys Raymond so everything Italian I
went in for yeah I went in for and that
taught me how to audition how to really
by 2002 I was a monster I knew exactly
what I was doing in the room I want to
tell how I my mother I met your mother's
and I walked in had no underwear I'm
just jeans but there was a little rip in
my jeans and they caught the table and
my [ __ ] came out I don't think it was
three women on the producer session and
I looked them all at the face and they
looked at me like oh just see the Cuban
they grow they buddy you know when you
say that line you got two things you to
get out of our office oh you know you
just killed this I had I didn't think
you could special story but a flap over
my dick and my hand like I was giving
signals for a fastball for the [ __ ]
and I walked out I'm down the block at
Fox then my agent calls they want you to
come back and read I wasn't there for 25
minutes just laughing talk about the
Cuban egg roll circumcised the whole
[ __ ] thing you know they got the road
if you watch How I Met Your Mother you
go you didn't belong in there they
weren't looking for me I just got him
with that right and I didn't mean
together you know you didn't plan that
Cuban 800 ripped you know many auditions
I went in to do you go to a lot of
auditions with no underwear another
thing know that one time I would look at
this smile I had to go to audition about
a neighbor Chris ABC pilot this was like
an American family this had to be 2000
two men walk in the room and every
[ __ ] big Italian actor is in there
and it was a scene where a guy had a
thong the typical Italian you know man
moves into like up upgrade this was his
living condition and now he's in his
yard water in the yard looking at the
neighbors and he's grilling hot dogs
with you know grilling a little Puerto
Rican grill you know the hibachi when
you get a little old one
and he's like living in Beverly Hills in
his mind and one of the neighbors comes
right he goes look at me you know I'm
living great so I'm reading this I'm
looking at all these Hollywood names and
they're these Italian guys like I got a
figure summer so I remembered I had I
put on like men's bikinis of purpose and
I go I'm gonna ask them if I cuz that's
what they said casting directors saying
if you go into an audition always asking
before you take a piece of clothing
sweats on over it I was 400 pounds
I'm gonna [ __ ] t-shirt huh when I walk
in there like thank you for coming
can you give us a minute and they turned
around to start looking at headshots
like oh this is my chance I took my
shirt off
I took my [ __ ] swept it off you
turned around I look at me living like a
doctor and they that was it like they
told me in the room listen tell those
people outside just to leave you booked
it cuz I knew how to get you took the
chance you have to take a chance the
chance it's just it's your people go to
audition to book a job I go to be
remember I go to rattle the pictures up
even though you're looking at Frank
Caliendo and even though you're looking
at Tony Soprano and even though you're
looking at Brad Pitt [ __ ] da si came
in here [ __ ] up our room yeah we gotta
do something with it yeah that's I mean
you and I learned the same lesson and
you applied it that's the big that's the
big difference as you go in there people
like it for ya you gotta be willing to
take the rejection on that
impersonations I could do no it's fine
but it's zero it's not even that it's
you take those chances in life and
that's they can really pay off
it's
amazing you don't realize how great that
is cuz they'll remember Q said you don't
have to book the job but you have to be
remembered because then they'll go and
sometimes the memory is not clear of
what you did like so you'll have done
something that did get something like
something but that guy he did something
I just bring him back well like when you
will I got here you see them Goodfellas
mm-hmm the guy that walks in I'm sorry
to say this on the podcast he walks into
a diner goes to later just stole my car
keys you know he got that you never seen
that guy get an anything he's a comic
from LA sweetheart of a guy right when I
first got out here I saw him the first
night I'm like you're the guy from good
for my head almost blew up like he was
at the improv doing the spot huh and we
became friends and I saw me audition I
said come one day how did you get
Goodfellas he was always in prison and I
read the book just like I did I read
Goodfellas impressed and left pardon and
and he goes when I came out I wrote
Scorsese letters letters letters and
when he cast Goodfellas he called me and
in Brooklyn
this idiot walked in took a gun out and
put it on the desk and he sat down he
goes I'm here and Scorsese said okay
security go get this guy at my building
they squatted him out right a month
later he goes I got a line for you I bet
that guy can't go into black
neighborhoods today or going to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and black people and
they're gonna go aren't you from
Goodfellas he's gonna go no no that was
a mistress at the end of the podcast and
I walked out that's all I'm saying
no no no but think about that I mean he
was remembered and they said I could
just see Scorsese going what idiot will
do this line of the movie like I can
just see such crazy going I gotta find
the guy to say you know two movies just
on my truck on national TV yes what can
I get the guy with the gun that retards
that's my name anyway Betty oh joy Diaz
this is just a guy did affright Kelly no
impression how I was on MADtv for five
years
how do you feel about it I didn't love
it it was I never got the other one we
never did was John mad and stuff and at
the beginning that's probably where I
should have been but I started working I
remember doing a sketch where I'd worked
on it really really hard to play an
original character guy rich Talarico sat
down with me wrote this great sketch I
was a little piece of it but he really
wrote that most of it was athletic
trainer physical trainer who need to get
to the training facility had to go
upstairs and was winded like he should
not have been at like the drops the tile
he picks it up with his foot like Oh God
okay second I pick it up like the
person's like aren't you gonna bend down
and get that like oh that's just I just
do the stairs this is tough
I get nailed the the table read and
everyone's like Frank that was Fantasma
is like that was awesome Frank never saw
you never seen you do anything like that
at all really cool can't wait to see
that sketch made everybody you know
pumping it up and they never made this
cuss they tabled it and had me do
another John mad sketch and that's when
I knew they were never going to give me
an opportunity to do anything outside of
that take a chance and something outside
of the impressions and I was like I'm
I'm done here this is I don't care
anymore I'll ride this out and the same
time I got the NFL on Fox job with
Bradshaw on how he longed and those guys
and being around Hall of Fame NFL guys
that's what brought me up that's what
made me that's what got me into the
corporate comedy world which is where
all the money is and stuff like that so
I I didn't I didn't even care MADtv let
me do that one year I even got out of
like ten episodes of Mad TV because I
said it was too much of a workload but
it was really just I didn't like what I
was doing at MADtv I was doing more
stuff at the NFL on Fox and was a
football show so I didn't have a great
time there but again I didn't push
myself and fight for myself I watched
the guys like keegan-michael key and
and Pele who were there later when I was
just ending and trying to get out of
there really and Will Sasso before me
and if I to learn those lessons they
were the ones fighting for themselves
and right in on the writing of their own
sketches even if they those guys wrote
their own sketches key and peele did and
that's why I think their stuff went over
so well they didn't even break until
they did key and Peele were they a
hundred percent were in control of
editing and stuff like that I remember
there was a point where Jordan Peele
they're like the the powers that be at
MADtv is like this guy doesn't work for
this show I'm like what are you talking
about he's a genius
then I wasn't the only one that saw it
not trying to say that but I'm like
watching and Kegan was another one I was
like this guy should be on Santa live
every every sketch he does would be you
know played everywhere the next day it
was one of those things where you could
just see magic when I first went to
MADtv I did a John Madden thing go
figure
and it was talking about war and
something they started playing it on
different news shows and like Manatee
was like they were getting publicity but
these guys had like totally original
created stuff that you're going if they
were on Sara alive and Jordan stuff was
more subdued but just really brilliantly
written and Keegan stuff was big
over-the-top characters that you would
just see breaking out as sattell I've
and there'd be a toy made and in shirts
the next day and you get these guys they
direct it and they drove their own stuff
and kind of told the directors and the
producers this is how we're doing it and
they got the stuff they wanted made made
the way they wanted to and that's how it
really works if you can do that and have
the confidence in yourself because
there's so many people around you
telling no you have to listen to this
person and I was one of those people
that listen you can get a lot better
done and you might have a reputation of
being a tougher person Oriya that's not
really that you're just standing up for
your setting up we used to stand and I
never stood up for me I heard sad man
live with doggie-door I don't think it's
as much as it used to be like if
everybody had a call Prime at 10:00 you
would have to be that eight to pull the
producers aside yeah and the writers and
say take a look at this no yeah we have
some but you had a I talked that talked
to me like Dana Carvey and some of the
other people around those time
that were like yeah you to write your
own sky no this at that doesn't even
come from that was from something that I
heard David Spade talk about it where
David Spade talked about you can't you
would have to write the stuff with the
writers and then perform it make sure
you were in on the writing because if
you let writers just write stuff they'd
give it to the people who are already
famous like the the more famous people
on the show that already broken
they want their sketches made and talked
about right so you don't give it to the
new person you give it to the new person
there's a chance there's a better chance
of failure on your sketch you write it
you come up with it you give it to the
main people because they're gonna sell
you give it to Will Ferrell at the time
you give it to whoever's there and you
know that's that's gonna break right you
or at least has a chance you give it to
somebody who's unknown might be thrown
at the end of the show because one of
the big you know three or four isn't in
it and that you don't want the throwaway
sketch you want the show you want the
show opener or in the top three sketches
because that's when everybody's watching
and cares about it unless it's something
crazy that happens weird at the end like
a you know Tracy Morgan scratch that the
first times like I'm Brian fellows and
it's like it's so weird that it takes
off because of that but you won't want
that up front because it's not the right
time or feel but later it becomes that
it works its way in but as a writer you
want to give the stuff to the star if
you're if those stars saying your words
man yeah you ever done this you're in a
table read and for the people who listen
to the podcast you don't know what table
read is it's when the first run-through
and read-through of a sketch or a sitcom
or whatever and you say something and
who's laughing the person who wrote it
like that like three writers like you
say some it's it's kind of funny but
there's three people one and nobody else
is laughing in the room and you don't
understand at the beginning but then
it's three three times in you know three
three table reads in you're like wait a
second they wrote that that's why
they're laughing and then the writers
are only laughing at their own stuff
they're shutting down other people's
stuff I'm not saying all people do this
but I think it's part of human nature
like you want your stuff to do well and
you're you know you're encouraging your
own things like sometimes you'd read
something a table read and you'd get a
nervous laugh or hey
like that kind of like they're not sure
if it's funny or not and nobody else is
laughing but the writer thing and like
you're going I don't want to take you to
realize all this is [ __ ] I mean I
think I knew pretty early on but I am
listen I'm a cynic from the beginning I
I've never liked anything I've done
I bet for the most part I looked at
anything I've ever done and I going I
don't know I I'm a realist and people
when they meet me end up saying oh you
didn't think that was good and I thought
that sucked what do you think about the
thing I thought that was pretty good and
I'm really proud of this but most of the
stuff I did along the way was a lot of
acquiescing a lot of giving in and
compromising to other people's ideas ago
it's good but it wasn't my vision it's
not
I watched Frank TV stuff the show you
came on with me and and I go oh man I
should have watched the editing of this
because this is really written well but
by the time it got through three
different layers of editing they chopped
out all the air and it's you need space
you need time in between lines and you
can't cut out setups because if you
don't have the setups it's just a bunch
of punchlines and there's no context to
what the joke is
it's not a joke if it's just a punchline
it's a setup that doesn't make sense you
know if you don't have a set up in the
joke you need you need to say why did
they go to the store to write up the
chicken cross the road if you just said
to get to the other side what's why I
don't get it and that's what a lot of
times they would do on in my show when I
watch I go oh man they're just doing to
get to the other side they're not doing
the setup in it I don't even know how it
got there and it's comedies evolved I
think to like look at your podcast
you're a comedian you're known as a
funny person you're funny in the moments
that need to be funny the rest of the
time you're interesting night I started
this podcast with these guys it's all
about comic books and superheroes and
stuff like that because I want to show
people a different side of me and I said
don't try to be funny on it and it is
it's it's it's all interrupting each
other and saying it's like try to be
interesting be interesting and people
will care because I mean even your voice
Joey your voice I listen to you have
that deep bass in your voice
and you have a way talking and you get
to it but I want I'm willing to listen
and wait and it pays off a lot of time
to find out I want to know what you did
and how you got to that but you have
that it's a lot of people they don't
they just want to be funny
and trying to be funny that's well
that's the one-liner guy we talked about
cast yeah
the podcast I quoted earlier and people
trying to be cute it's not gonna work
this time
everybody's funny hey I've caught myself
everybody's I've caught myself ten times
going hey do I try and do this little
bitty thing here and I go no no that's
that that's not this place this place is
just talk in it like because it's
different I don't know if it's different
for you you can tell me if you feel the
same way
but when I go on like a radio station or
something like that I'm on there for 20
minutes or however long I've got a job
to do and that's sell tickets because I
want to make the money they're here it's
more like I want to be in your world I
want to be part of you well if I came in
here as jokey in the first ten minutes
you're going hey great five kids done
and I love say the word podcast babka I
don't know when because we had a time
issue thing and it was it cracked me cuz
it made me realize it made me learn
something about podcast to you you've
actually taught me a lot in a little bit
of time is you have a brand you care
about it you want it to be something
don't mess with it and get and I
sometimes just get my podcasts over with
if we don't have something I feel is
great because at the beginning you're
just trying to figure your way out but I
said hey I got to catch this 4:30 flight
I got to be out of here at 3:30 and do
you text you don't text a lot you call
right because I've had a second text
something other than that yeah I would
just think about I will just pick up the
[ __ ] phone Jesus Christ
yeah and I've trouble with it's like
people on Facebook how are you doing I'm
doing great and then you go back to
doing what you're doing and they stand
now they want to have a conversation and
I'm like listen that's not gonna I don't
give you the how you doing I just go
right into the questions but I realized
early on it's gonna be a phone call so
actually I gotta get we were gonna
record this at 2 o'clock and like I got
to catch a 4:30 flight out of Burbank
it's only 10 minutes oh I got to get out
there about 3:15 can I don't realize you
know I do 45-minute podcast right now
because we don't have the audience we're
not we're trying to build we're trying
to find out who we are I think it's a
waste of time for me to do that much
time so I don't realize you'll just go
until you feel it's over and old wrapper
appears I've been doing them sure listen
nobody has the stamina to go three hours
Li nobody could sit there for three but
I'm not I'm not saying I want something
it's like if you call me tomorrow right
it's a Joey I want you to be on Frank TV
I love you Joey don't come in to eight
o'clock the more you show up around 2:30
and I go to you Frank I gotta leave at
3:30 you know you know what I don't want
to put you through that and I don't want
to put myself right because this guy's
gonna be taping in the whole time he's
talking about the traffic on the 405 I
don't need that I should have had when I
shot both days no no what I should have
done cuz I'd already changed the time on
you a couple times trying to fix things
I was trying to say hey I really want to
do this and I didn't want to make it
earlier and then what I should have done
is called you and realized then we don't
have a text to look back at and you can
see how many times I've changed you're
not going to find remember so it's like
then you said I and I got scared I'm
like no I want to do this this is where
I'm trying to go in my career life
whatever I couldn't wait to be here like
I did I did a lot of things this in
these last couple days and how long have
you been in their life for just two days
what do you think I mean how what did
you let me but let me but when you said
let's just do it another time
I got scared to death and that's when I
called you in like or you called me and
I'm like oh no no no no mr. Diaz can we
please please please please please can
we do that like I was like no and then
you said well let's do it at 1:00 why
want to give it no I guess justice but
it taught me that if you learn something
and not even that it it's the show and
you were a hundred percent right don't
try and fit it in do it right
and I'm like I can do it right and then
we even you said 1:30 I'm like I can be
there at 1:00 you like I'll be there at
1:00 we will be at 12:30 I I it's Frank
you know it's like you shoot Monday
through Thursday
everybody knows Frank Caliendo least
[ __ ] Friday to make his real money
he's doing a favor for you and all of a
sudden I come out here before you wrap
and go you gotta be here tomorrow
right even though your flights it - are
you gonna focus yeah you can't careful
100% learn I learned this as a Kyler in
this during analyze that in 2002 when
they said I was the first seen up and
you'll be out of there by two o'clock so
I booked Rascals today and guess what
happened when I got there
you can't shoot early the bar won't let
you shoot till four o'clock I'm like oh
no I got the whole week in that rascals
opening up a rocky Laporte it's
wednesday night and now i'm you trying
to say you and rocky Laporte he didn't
like me now there's now i'm trying to
open up the [ __ ] I'm trying to do my
line and I can't because I'm thinking
about the 32 minute ride right - rascal
yeah that's why I said people left
give me a time when did you move to
Arizona when did you decide on Arizona
oh right here for a while
yeah I cold water in Ventura somewhere
around it was originally owned by Bud
Abbott which was bar the reason I bought
the house from Abbott and Costello right
behind the Ralph's over there and so I
think I'm Mike daughter was born I
didn't wanna raise my kids in LA I'm
like I think I just want to in Phoenix
was a place where it was a lot of people
from the Midwest who just didn't want to
be cold anymore I just felt like so much
was fake out here I didn't trust
anything and I was like we can either
move way out and then I might as well
just fly in to the airport anyways so
that was 13 years ago so 13 years ago I
I was gonna they're gonna be Vegas or
because I thought it might work there
but then I looked at Vegas I'm like it
was it a obviously a terrible place to
raise kids to so I settled on Phoenix
and like that because it's just real
everyday regular people my wife's from
Cleveland she would she I think she
liked that more the desert scape you
know not a lot of grass she missed that
but in terms of you know just having a
neighborhood it was it was the right
move because we have like really nice
neighborhood everything's right around
us and it's pretty safe feeling so I was
even shooting my show the Frank TV show
I was flying in to do that every week
and I had two guys Freddy Lockhart and
Mike McCrae they were living at my house
I had him Houston like yeah
is that yeah that's what yeah yeah he's
a brilliant guy to a guy he showed up to
a car I knew him before you got the show
okay from Houston as a feature yeah and
then you know now I think he lives in
Austin now yeah it's kind of like me
where he went and did his own thing
yeah he just have a family people come
in they go this isn't for me yeah I like
it I get it and he's brilliant I mean do
Letterman yeah he didn't I actually
think I helped him get on that was an
impressionist thing right and I'm like
you got to see this guy he does this
incredible Harrison Ford and Eddie Brill
might have seen him before that or
something like that but they they
brought him on and he just killed he
just slayed he's he's really really good
and just a brilliant writer as a
stand-up comedian and he did a bunch of
cartoon voices I think and I think he
was even the voice of Buzz Lightyear for
some toys yeah so he did a bunch of
things but that was one way or I was
trying to get more people on my show
that like wanted to be the Frank
Caliendo show just Franken I'm like how
about some other people and they let me
have a couple cast members and those
were the guys that got picked
Melissa Villa Senor she was she was on
the show and I love going back and
looking at people's BIOS cuz it's so
funny and now because she was on
America's Got Talent or wanted that I
think that's the show her first show she
made her television debut on on
America's Got no no no no no she was on
Frank TV not that it matters but I was
like I've been erased from history there
come on
I had a couple people on that I'm very
proud that I fought for and because I
got yeah my Miami beat it well people
people work but people there were people
that they network or the producers like
now I'm like no this I really want this
person on I think that they're funny
they're my name be 100% right but
they'll be funnier than the people
you've got that you're bringing in to me
in this situation I think it's the right
person I would fight funny I would fight
for my own person some more than I'd
fight for myself at times and I think
I'm actually better at that because I I
just didn't some self-worth kind of
thing or something along the way my dad
used to tell me that he's like Frank you
don't have any confidence I'm like III
but I don't know it's just me it's where
I'm coming from it's Who I am so you got
to have confidence you still work for
Fox
no no no because I went to ESPN couple
years ago it's so funny I haven't been
on the NFL on Fox for years and people
still think I'm on there on that
football show because I was there for
nine years I've been gone for probably
eight myself but northwestern sports no
that's not even on anyone nobody you I
did some of that that's how they got me
that that's how I got that show is cuz I
went on it did a bunch of other
impressions other than John Madden and
Jimmy Kimmel was leaving and a couple
other people were going to audition and
there's some pretty big people it was it
was Billy Gardell and Craig plays they
he's very funny was on the office Craig
Robinson brilliantly funny P they did a
point-counterpoint think Jeff Dunham was
gonna do a thing with puppets every week
and I got the job and Dunham wrote about
it in his book he told me like that was
the best thing that ever could have
happened for him but he didn't get that
job cuz he started working on some other
things and doing some different stuff
but I got that job it was perfect for me
for the time but I got lazy I started
just I didn't it was should've been a
second job I made it at first and got
complacent with it was like I'm making a
lot of money and I'm really happy right
now and it was such a big thing but I
also didn't fight for myself to beat me
in anything I I should have thought to
have myself in some of the sketches as
myself like playing off the characters
or something which I ended up doing some
on Frank TV which really helped but then
it was just I was just the impressions
and you couldn't you can't get other
stuff from that they need to see you be
something else
Rob Riggle does that show now and he
does the characters and it plays himself
and - yes and and he plays though that
he gets other movie parts he was in
movies before great movies and stuff
like that but you play other things and
people only see is one thing I just
pigeon-holed myself so much into that
that I'm looking at it going I should
have done that definitely fought for
myself to be you know give a little more
of myself one of the first ones it
didn't work they put me at a bar I'm not
again I've never added I never been
drunk and I'm a bartender and I'm
throwing to the impression thing it was
kind of a weird thing they want because
Kimmel was on a couch which made sin I'm
like I should be on a couch I'm a
regular guy that's what I am if there's
anything I'm to play it's the your name
who has you know a couple kids or
something like that I'm not the
bartender I'm pretending to be a
bartender right there from where we
talked about the very beginning truth
there's no truth in it it didn't work
and I do find truth and the impressions
believe it or not it seems like it might
be the opposite but it's really me
coming through the impression but I was
I was faking I just did what they said
they're like let's make you a bartender
a pizza delivery guy and then you become
the character and I said yes okay
looking for the gimmick it was too
gimmicky they cut it out I just went
straight to the impressions of the
sketch but it didn't do anything for me
in terms of helping me build a career it
just made me the guy who puts the the
wig on and the makeup and now you're the
impression the German the token the--
yeah I made it I made his grandkids
laugh at the Super Bowl one time this
wasn't Alice at the Four Seasons Hotel
and Jimmy Johnson standing next to a
football coach not the racecar driver
I'm like Jimmy do believe I'm close to
this close to John music what yeah many
mint taps men on the shoulder man looks
like what oh and the look on his face
when he saw me was pure horror it was
like the guy you know like it's like
when Shaggy and Scooby see the bad guy
pop out of the barrel let's get out of
here Scoob it was this terrible look
that went over his face and but I made
his grand kids laugh and when his
grandkids laugh I was like I got it like
it came through I said I'm like can I
get a picture with you and up until then
he hated me and I know that's true
because network executives had told me
like I did a commercial all right right
yeah this is almost a Joey Diaz level
commercial but a little safer but on the
same side so there's a a commercial
where John Madden's gonna sing with some
NASCAR driver sing Christmas carols and
I go I they wanted me to audition for it
I go first of all I'm not auditioning
for a John Madden voiceover as his voice
you can either just there's a lot of
things I would audition for that's not
one of them listen just listen to me
somewhere and you'll know I'm the guy
who's pigeon-holed himself is John man
so I go and I'm like there I'm like
what's the song just Knox roasting on an
open fire and it sounds like you mean
like this is unbelievable but I made
them pay me to go to the audition
I don't know if anybody's ever done that
before I made them pay me $1500 to
audition for something and they said we
don't pay for an audition that's
ridiculous I go he's not gonna let it
happen
so this is the job the job is me
spending my time to go in there you need
to pay me $1,500 so they paid me $1,500
after seeing a tape I did it they're
like this is incredible you sound
exactly like him and he saw it asked who
it was of the management asked or made
me an agent and I didn't get the job
and they like they were all crazy like
this is incredible you're right on the
money we didn't think we'd find anything
and then you watch the commercial I
watched I saw the commercial one day
later it's like chestnuts roasting on an
open fire like it's like they wanted
completely joking but they could have
had it and there's a way before that
that that for that this does the story
at the hotel but then he met me and
realized and just a regular guy I'm just
I'm having fun with this it's a joke
it's it's not to try and destroy him a
lot of people think when you do an
impression of them you're trying to
destroy and hurt them it's a form of
flattery it can be but it's also they're
worried is gonna hurt their money I
don't think some of them don't care
about unless it's a bad [ __ ]
depression right and if it's a great
impression like what you were doing him
is great Alec Baldwin is [ __ ] the
president is horrible well he's ain't
garbage I mean it's a thing and it's
only gonna get a show just every time I
watch that show what I gonna shrug
here's the thing this is a tough thing
for me because I have an audience my
audience is across the board and I
always want to respect people no matter
where they are even if I disagree with
them in comedy my job is to be silly
kind of Steve Martin thinking like I
want to I want to get you out there and
went and I want you to forget stuff even
I'm gonna do a trump I can't not do a
Trump impression because he's out these
what everybody knows him that audiences
are so segmented oh but he watches the
same stuff like peep things winning
Emmys are marvelous marvelous miss basil
and basil and all these different great
shows but it's so segmented nobody knows
everybody knows politicians and a lot of
people know sports but I'm gonna go out
there and I have people walking out just
because I go that was the number one
impression and people are just mad
because it's Trump and that they might
be a huge Trump supporter Mike listen
and not
whatever I'm not trying to make you mad
just listen it's jokes and I'm talking
about a personality I did it with Bush I
did it with Obama I did it everywhere
with all these people now all of a
sudden I can't just make you you know
easy not easy but like non political
jokes there's nothing political about
this it's just silly but I walk that
line and if you decide that you hate me
because I'm doing that or I get this -
you're not being mean enough to Trump
what do you mean that's not who I am you
mean - not you want to be angry about
there's things I don't like I get it I
get why you might not like I might I get
why somebody I also understand somebody
might like them because of something cuz
they've compartmentalized we all do that
in life like I mean it's terrible but
listen it'll help me and if you're ever
that's everybody's out there for
themselves in some way you don't admit
that you are you be people won't admit
that they won't admit we're all selfish
we all have a selfishness about them
about ourselves admit that so I'm out
there and my selfishness is I'm trying
to make money and I'm trying to offend
this least amount of people possible and
just be silly I'm not gonna be as angry
as you know it it feels like when Alec
Baldwin is doing that they feel like
he's playing to a severe II specific
audience and that's fine you can do that
because he's got that audience he's at
that level of an actor I'm playing for
everybody I still travel I yes and no
it's up and down depending on what my
kids are doing so I'll go do a date here
and day there when I'm working on now is
I'll go to do I will go and do a night
and work on I like doing clubs a lot
more because I'm working on changing Who
I am so in a club I can get that feeling
of the closeness the proximity of the
audience and I can try a lot of stuff
that I'd never try on a theater stage or
a casino stage you know you go to a
casino those are 50 $60 tickets to go up
there and goof around and then I don't
live in LA to go do a bunch of guest
sets all the time and work on stuff I
work on stuff I go do an hour hour and
15 minutes and 20 minutes will be
totally different stuff and sometimes
another ten minutes of goofing around
and then I'll give them the best of
stuff that they and some people paid to
see because there's people who still I'm
like a rerun for a lot of people I mean
not on TV but on on stage people will
come to see certain things
and it's you know it's like it's it's
like a Brian Regan thing there's gonna
cup of dirt and people are calling stuff
out so traveling yes and I picked the
times I just picked the time when they
find you these savages at Frank on stage
calm is the easiest thing um there's a
couple California dates there's a doing
the improv and a little bit I'm not sure
when we're airing exactly so Niagara
Falls at the Seneca Niagara is great
yeah fantastic love them
there's Houston improv boys yeah and and
the diode show will be a little bit
different rich Richfield Connecticut at
the at the Richfield Playhouse but
that's a smaller 500 seater I can I can
mess around a little bit there but at at
Frank Caliendo on Twitter at Frank Kelly
on Oster Instagram I've been working on
the Instagram make you take a couple
pictures with me because I neglected
that I didn't yeah those world that's
all that it's it's it's a mistake that I
made and I look back and go I bet on
vine and Twitter and Twitter's all angry
people and information direct and or
directly at you and vine died went away
and that inspires good yeah oh yeah for
a while Jesus that's how I'm glad if I
am yeah well I look at you like your
Instagram you got eight hundred thousand
or million or something like that I go
wow that's it and the podcasting side if
i am i plug in too much right now but i
started doing that al Jackson and I you
know L know he's very very funny guy did
the had a thing that went viral a couple
years ago I saw him I'm like wow this is
this is what I want to do I want to talk
that's it's called Alan Frank try to be
serious and it's we actually talk about
political topics without being political
that's like it wasn't that I - yeah
iTunes and everything it's a we're we
haven't even tried to put it on
something bigger yet cuz we're still
developing right now and trying to find
our complete voice we all have been
doing like a couple months so you know
how it is you start to get along the way
and you start to feel it and then you
start to bring guests on and then you
can do newer things and we're just
making sure our come because we he does
it from Denver and I'm in Phoenix and we
do
over the internet so and we've got that
down but now when you bring a guest in
it's it's a little bit more difficult
and I think that's really how you grow
you have interesting guests and you know
everybody social media emerges and
everybody talks about each other and
your other audiences find you like most
of my audience like I think that I don't
know the last time I said we've been
sitting here for what hour and a half or
simply oh yeah I'm not again I'm not
worried about that I got plenty of time
okay you do okay when's the last time I
sat down and just talked with somebody
for this long I threw a couple voices in
some people remember it's me
but it's like this is me and this is who
I am that's the people see that a little
bit and that's why I started that comic
playground podcast that's on iTunes -
it's so people can see another version
of me and I'll do all the stuff I'll do
the puppet show that's part of what I do
is throwing that stuff in here and there
but when people like we said at the very
we know you know where I'm coming from
it's easier to latch on it's easier to
know the purse it's better to know I was
so I've always been so amazed I go and
watch somebody like Lewis Black and
there are elements of polished stuff but
he's just talking at times you just you
do it - you can just tell the story home
you talk but it bring them down a
humanity level yeah but it's hard to do
it like in it but when people you have
you ever opened for a music act yes
people go there with the mindset I want
to listen to music and you're up there
doing jokes and I'm my own band playing
after myself because people are waiting
for the impressions and I'm just talking
for a while here's this is one like
years ago this is right I think it was
after that might have been before Vegas
I don't know was but Celine Dion's
people wanted me to go on the road with
Celine Dion to open for Celine I'm like
what audience do you think I like I'm
known for sports stuff I have a lot more
to me but that's what I've shown people
but I'm definitely not for Celine Dion's
audience unless it's for all the
husbands and boyfriends
see could you imagine
couldn't even think about like I would
have died at in that what they ended up
getting was a singing impressionist
which okay that makes sense you didn't
want the guy who at the time did the
John Madden and the you know the
President Bush or whether whoever was
there at the time like okay at least
that I know why they came from me but
they were they were offering like money
it was an incredible money but it was
good money to go tour with Celine Dion a
lot of people just said yes I'm like I'm
gonna tank at this it's just and I don't
want to adapt no people have opened up a
chair and died that's a that's two
different [ __ ] that yeah I like stand
up you know if it's the Allman Brothers
I'm gonna OD I'm in I don't wanna ban
and do drugs
[ __ ] the left always Motley Crue and get
syphilis I mean I'm open to lead the on
and drink bottled water get the [ __ ] out
of it we we are so the same person yeah
there's one thing I've learned today you
and I are mirror images of each other in
life asleep yeah I'm gonna stab myself
sometimes I've lived such a clean I've
lived a pretty crime listen I've got
flaws and I've been a pretty bad person
times my life but I you're one of those
guys it's like when I watched tombstone
and watched Val Kilmer play Doc Holliday
I wanted to be somewhere along the line
you [ __ ] somebody in the ass maybe
college you came in somebody's mouth you
ain't no [ __ ] angel Frank Caliendo
next time you're in town you're always
welcome on our lot to come back thank
you very much for taking the time thank
you or anything and call me and I'll get
you up on segura oh yeah do a little
let's get you out oh I'd love that
yeah hold for a couple weeks get your
head together yeah and calming though
yeah but you I love that yeah I'm gonna
start networking yeah you have to this
is like I'm recent no I don't listen I
will go this [ __ ] gets up at
4:00 and calls three [ __ ] radio
stations every day you invented this it
was a chain I did I didn't have just
changed yeah you in fact with this you
were the one that put the [ __ ] listen
listen let me tell you about
opportunities missed there was a time I
was the number one thing on YouTube
before
cat that has a heart
HAC but you know something like that
took over I was the number one thing on
YouTube with the Bush versus Clinton
comparison now this is before subscribe
I have almost no subscriptions because I
didn't follow up on it the original one
still gets a couple thousand hits a day
and it's Bill Clinton versus george w
bush how are they alike and how are they
different kind of thing
but there was a like writers and
bloggers were calling it the Frank
Caliendo effect before YouTube was the V
thing I was number one on it for a while
and this is and this is before history
of dance it still probably only has 15
million things but I had two million
when people had ten thousand it's time
to you like gladiator
it's time to get [ __ ] Rome back I want
to thank you I want to thank the
[ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
savages for listening to the show and
supporting us every week with your plug
your commercials at the beginning of
sponsors maybe I've never heard anybody
[ __ ] you why would ya know I got a
cell it's right now we're living in an
r-rated world if you ever does r-rated
commercials on the internet first gonna
make millions of dollars yeah every else
is just foolish flowers that's a
memorable I can't I want to hear the I
told me yesterday how many how many
actual can you like my uncle you getting
angry probably actually gave you a
compliment you get in are the actual
commercial campaigns are there any more
that you would get a call ten years ago
and say you're shooting 10 Kia
commercials you're shooting for Kia
commercials there's no more campaigns
knowing it's all on the internet so when
somebody comes someone goes hi Harry's
plumber let me unplug your [ __ ] for
you that guy it's gonna [ __ ] Kenneth
thousand calls that day oh
I want to thank Frank the [ __ ]
and I want to thank you guys for
supporting the show and go see Frank and
Connecticut Houston and Seneca you know
I love you [ __ ] new Canadians
come down and watch Frank Caliendo and
learn something stop [ __ ] sitting up
there looking at a flag with a leaf on
it all right I want to thank Frank I
want to thank the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but most important I want to thank you
guys do
forget there's one show available a late
show for Saturday night and milk
Milwaukee you guys are gonna wrap it to
myself in beam del Rey Minneapolis is
all [ __ ] sold out within that a second
show Milwaukee we got the second show
we're ready for you get ready to rock
bring the reefer bring the heroin bring
them with sugar the pills whatever you
got will [ __ ] going deep all right
like I said I want to thank Frank I want
to thank the [ __ ] but you guys
always hit it out of the park oh and now
for a word from our sponsors let me tell
you something all right grip is the
better electronic tube of the electric
toothbrush created by dentist and
designers quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable one of the
most important things we do for our
health every day is brushing our teeth
yeah most of us do not do it properly
all right number one they got a
multi-use cover that mounts to your
mirror and a nun mounts the slide over
your bristles for on-the-go brushing why
it declutter is your spin to your sink
space and cabinet and makes traveling
with the electric toothbrush easier
quick doesn't require clunky charge and
runs for three months three months on
one charge this the sonic vibrations is
gentle enough on your sensitive gums
people brush too hard and someone like
the toothbrushes are too abrasive I know
the ones I've had before that's why I
stopped using them they just [ __ ] up
my gun not we quit quickly quit keeps
your mouth clean and has a pulsar which
changed which buzzes every 30 seconds to
remind you when to switch sides it's
helping you guide to a full and even
clean and the brush heads are
automatically delivered and the dentists
recommend is recommended schedule every
three months for just five hours all
right three out of four of us bristles
we brush our teeth with toothbrushes and
an old worn out and effective it ends
today wit is the way to go it's one of
the first electric toothbrushes accepted
by the American Dental Association has
thousands of verified five-star reviews
what I'm gonna do for you is this all
right
I love quick because the clutters it has
the sonic vibrations and the best thing
I like about it is a two-minute pulsar
that's
tremendous alright these new reasons why
I love quit but the main reason is cuz
they're backed by 20,000 dental
professionals
Krim starts at 25 hours and if you go to
get quit calm slash joy right now you
get your first refill pack for free
three [ __ ] three days after taxes I'm
giving it away [ __ ] for free
that's your first refill pack for free
and get quick calm slash Joey go to get
quick calm and get the best electric
razor our best electric razor the best
electric toothbrush in the market today
all right
the podcast is also brought to you by
manscaped every time my wife cuts trims
around the [ __ ] beanpole on my
nutsack my blood pressure's raises one
hundred and sixty over the [ __ ]
hundred don't cut your dick off [ __ ] all
the suffering and the anxiety ends today
with manscape you get it done right
without the pain and suffering you're
gonna feel like Jesus before he got
killed nothing like that they got
precision tools for your family
[ __ ] jewels manscaped has
redesigned the electric razor their
invention is the lawn mower a handheld
razor with skin-safe technology so it
won't Nick or snag you a little [ __ ]
sack it's very gentle older you get the
thinner the skin gets you got to go easy
on what the Lord gave you this bad boy
will leave you clean smooth and
pain-free plus it's rechargeable and
very easy to hold
get it on all the looks and the [ __ ]
crannies manscape will get you a little
beanbag looking like Lee's [ __ ] head
when he shaves smooth as a [ __ ] egg
and I'm not gonna let you get off with
the little secret if you trim the hedges
that [ __ ] beanpole look a lot bigger
what the [ __ ] you waiting for trim
that [ __ ] egg roll with manscape now
at manscape comm you get everything you
need to make your ball shine and keep
your dick looking like a [ __ ] Mona
Lisa you understand me if this is the
first time you've considered manscaping
they got the deal for you and this is
the first time you consider manscaping
you should be ashamed of yourself you
filthy [ __ ] animal manscape has the
perfect package which comes with a
lawnmower and a safety razor plus the
crop preserver you like Joey what's the
crop
it's a specially formulated deodorant so
your balls don't stick like a dead
[ __ ] body you understand me right now
sniff your balls they look like nips
they smell like Nipsey Hussle 'he's
[ __ ] free these been in the casket
for a week get your life together
[ __ ] and the revival is a sprint
stepped out and refreshing your junk to
keep your nutsack cool like a [ __ ]
ice cube because you don't want your
balls hot especially now it's summertime
coming listeners can go to church right
now and get 20% of your first order you
use the code church at manscape calm
right now if you're one of the perfect
package don't also throw in a free
travel bag when you use the code Church
that's manscape calm use promo code
church and get 20% off your first order
listen [ __ ] summers coming
keep your nutsack clean the podcast is
also brought to you by on it number one
when it comes to supplements in my
[ __ ] book who else gives you a
thousand for brain don't work for you we
give you 100% money-back guarantee we
let you keep the [ __ ] product that's
pride that's commitment that's something
a lot of companies don't have today
honor is the way to go towards just
shoot check immune the shrimp export the
[ __ ] jerky the protein pilots
everything or Bri goes out of his way to
make everything the number one that he
gets I've had conversation on how long
he searched for the cacao for the
[ __ ] protein probably took him like a
year to find the perfect [ __ ] cocoa
whatever the [ __ ] in his co-ceo way I
don't know how to spell I left back in
the seventh grade but anyway with all
that said go to honored comrade now if
you like the vitamins if you like what
you read I'm the checkout press in
church and get 10% off the living right
to your [ __ ] house no drama no
nothing okay that's how it works so go
to on it and give them a look over and
time I can't do none fee on the weights
in the bathroom the kettlebells I can
help you with the supper so going on at
that time right now I'm pressing Church
and get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house
I want to thank on it I want to thank
quip electric toothbrushes and I also
want to thank manscape for sponsoring us
and the love they give us and we give
you the same love too don't forget
tickets still left for Milwaukee the
Pats mum
[ __ ] theater go to Pabst calm right
now or Wikipedia they'll tell you what
the site is I have no [ __ ] idea I got
enough on my [ __ ] hands I love your
[ __ ]
I want to thank Caliendo I want to thank
the mayor oh it's but again I want to
thank you guys for being a loyal fanbase
and we're not even fans were [ __ ]
family [ __ ]
have a great weekend we'll see you
Monday morning nice and [ __ ]
early kick this mule Lee